a ver tenemos aquí una matriz a de n por
n y pues vamos a escribirla bien tenemos
la primera fila que es a 11 a 12 y así
hasta llegar al ah1n después tenemos la
segunda fila a 21 a 22 hasta llegar al 2
ene y más adelante pues vamos a tener
alguna fila en que se llame a a1 a2
hasta llegar al a y en la décima fila y
después otra fila que se llama a j 1 j 2
hasta a jota n y finalmente llegamos a
la última fila que es la fila a n1 y n2
hasta a nm
observemos que aquí escribí con todas
sus letras a estas dos filas la fila y
la fila j porque las vamos a usar y
ahora pues vamos a definir bueno déjame
definir aquí vamos a tener un vector
aunque sea el vector y uno después
porque va a estar a 2 y así hasta llegar
a la entrada a y n esto no lo he
decidido formalmente pero este es un
vector file ok es un vector de hecho
incluso lo podemos ver como una matriz
de 1 por n porque tiene una fila y n
columnas
pero déjenme seguirle llamando un vector
de hecho vamos a ponerle aquí su gorrito
de vector aunque pues no sé por qué los
vectores que hemos visto hasta ahorita
eran puros vectores columna que
generalmente son verticales pero a éste
también lo podemos ver como un vector
y usando los podemos ver a esta matriz
de una forma mucho más simple mucho más
reducida y vamos a hacerlo así en este
vídeo y en los próximos entonces podemos
ver a esta matriz
cómo
r 1 y después r 2 y así nos seguimos por
aquí nos vamos a encontrar al ere y y
después al r j y finalmente vamos a
llegar al rm
ok lo que hacemos es tomar cada una de
estas filas y definir el vector fila
cuyas entradas son justo las entradas de
cada fila
ok entonces esta fila de aquí la tomamos
la convertimos en un vector y le
llamamos r 1 y hacemos lo mismo para
cada una de estas filas y entonces la
matriz a es simplemente la matriz que
contiene a cada uno de los vectores fila
la matriz que tiene en cada una de sus
filas al vector fila correspondiente a
cada uno de estos vectores tiene en
entradas porque hay n columnas entonces
esta es simplemente otra forma de
escribir esta matriz y ahora lo que
vamos a hacer es formar a otra matriz a
la cual le vamos a llamar la matriz ese
quijote que lo que va a hacer esta
matriz es justo intercambiar la fila y
con la fila j entonces tenemos aquí a la
matriz s y j
que en la primera fila va a tener a la
primera fila de a suponiendo que uno es
distinto de ahí y de jota o sea que no
escogimos intercambiar la primera fila
que fácilmente pudimos haber decidido
intercambiar la pero bueno todas las
pilas que no sean ni y ni jota van a ser
justo las mismas filas de a ok entonces
tenemos aquí a la primera fila digamos
que la segunda fila tampoco es ni iu ni
j y después nos seguimos poniendo todas
las filas hasta que llegamos al lugar
donde iría la décima fila entonces en
lugar de poner a la décima fila vamos a
poner a la j es imagina ok entonces aquí
ponemos en la fila j después nos
seguimos poniendo las mismas filas de la
matriz a hasta que llegamos al lugar de
la j décima fila y en lugar de poner la
j décima fila ponemos la décima fila
aquí ponemos el ie9 de ricota y el resto
de las pilas las dejamos tal cual como
están en la matriz a porque entonces
esta es igualita a la matriz excepto que
cambiamos la fila y la fila j del lugar
que estas dos pilas las intercambiamos
ahora lo que vimos hace algunos vídeos
bueno de hecho no estoy tan segura de
que lo hayamos visto pero sigue siendo
cierto es que si intercambiamos dos
files entonces el determinante de a es
exactamente igual a menos el
determinante de la matriz en la cual
intercambiamos dos filas y entonces
surge una pregunta muy interesante
aunque hay que pasa si dos filas por
ejemplo esta fila
esta fila son exactamente iguales
ok qué pasa cuándo rj es exactamente
igual a como se comportan sus
determinantes key que es lo que eso
significa significa que hay uno es
exactamente igual a aj que hay dos es
exactamente igual a aj dos que hay en es
exactamente igual a aj n y así con todos
los términos del medio y entonces si
estas dos filas son iguales cuando
veamos esta matriz que intercambia la
fila y con la fila j lo único que vamos
a ver es exactamente la misma matriz a
ok porque estamos intercambiando estas
dos filas del lugar pero son igualitas
entonces no se va a notar el cambio gay
entonces a ver déjame lo escribo bien
sí
y es exactamente igual a la fila
j entonces
entonces
lo que vamos a tener es que la matriz a
es exactamente igual a la matriz que
intercambia a la décima fila con la j
décima fila cierto y eso lo que implica
que tal vez debería de ponerlo de otro
color eso lo que implica es que el
determinante de la matriz a sea
exactamente igual al determinante de la
matriz s y j
por qué pues porque si tienes dos
matrices que son iguales sus
determinantes tienen que ser iguales
también ahora la matriz ese hijo está
como intercambia dos columnas entonces
nosotros sabemos aquí me faltó ponerle
una j
nosotros sabemos que se da esta igualdad
y esta igualdad la podemos multiplicar
por un -1 entonces aquí nos quedan menos
x menos más y aquí nos queda menos el
determinante de a entonces este
determinante también es igual
el determinante de a así es que tenemos
este resultado muy interesante en
particular nos interesa este pedazo de
la igualdad con este otro pedazo de la
igualdad porque eso lo que nos dice es
que el determinante de a es igual a
menos el determinante de a y esa es una
propiedad no muy común de hecho ya nada
más por saber que el determinante de a
es igual a menos el determinante de a
sabemos exactamente cuál es el
determinante de a
entonces tenemos que si las dos filas
son iguales entonces estas dos matrices
son iguales y por lo tanto sus
determinantes son iguales pero al mismo
tiempo como ese hijo está es la matriz a
intercambiando la fila y la fila jota
entonces nosotros sabemos que el
determinante de ese hijo está es igual a
menos el determinante de a aunque está
por aquí creo que lo vimos en otro vídeo
sino pues tú hacer las cuentas y como
conclusión tenemos que el determinante
vea es igual a menos el determinante de
a y eso yo digo que ya nos dice
exactamente cuánto vale el determinante
de a ok porque digamos cualquier número
x
si nosotros sabemos que x es igual a
menos x entonces forzosamente eso
implica que x tiene que ser igual a 0
aunque puedes pasar este menos x del
otro lado sumando y te queda 2x igual a
0 y después divididos entre 2 y te queda
x igual a 0 entre 2 que es igual a 0
aquí entonces finalmente cualquier
número que cumpla con esta propiedad
tiene que ser a fuerzas cero por lo
tanto estos tres puntitos indican por lo
tanto el determinante de a es
exactamente igual a cero pero bueno el
chiste es que si tienes filas duplicadas
ok voy a escribirlo
y les
duplex
si tienes filas duplicadas eso implica
que el determinante tiene que ser igual
a 0 lo cual tiene todo el sentido del
mundo o sea porque recuerda lo que vimos
hace algunos vídeos de que una matriz es
invertible si sólo si su forma
escalonada reducida por filas es igual a
la matriz identidad aunque hay a ver
vamos a escribirlo una matriz una matriz
es invertible es invertible invertible
si y sólo si su forma escalonada
reducida por filas es la matriz
identidad de la dimensión de nuestra
matriz original y si nosotros tenemos
que dos filas son igualitas
si tenemos por aquí que estas dos filas
son igualitas entonces a la hora de
tratar de llegar a la forma escalonada
reducida por filas lo que vamos a hacer
en algún punto es tomar esta fila y
reemplazarla por esta fila menos esta
fila y nos va a quedar aquí toda una
fila de ceros porque estas dos filas son
iguales y como vimos en ese vídeo de
forma escalonada reducida por filas o en
el vídeo de matrices inversas
si llegas en algún punto a que la matriz
tiene una pila de ceros
ya sabemos que nunca vamos a poder
reducirla a la matriz identidad ok y por
lo tanto esta matriz no es invertible
entonces ya sabemos que matrices que
tienen filas duplicadas cuando las
reduzcamos a su forma escalonada
reducido por filas nunca nos van a dar
una matriz identidad
la reducción
reducción a su forma escalonada reducida
por filas de matrices matrices con una
triste es una s con filas duplicadas
duplicada
nunca nunca
puede ser la matriz identidad gay puede
la matriz matriz
identidad
y por lo tanto tenemos que las matrices
con pilas duplicadas no son invertibles
no
invertir
keiko bien todo este texto y peguen lo
aquí y nos dice que las matrices con
filas duplicadas no son invertibles pero
además nosotros sabemos que eso pasa si
y sólo si el determinante de la matriz
es 0 por lo tanto todas las matrices que
tienen filas duplicadas su determinante
a fuerzas tiene que ser cero entonces ya
mostramos de dos formas distintas
completamente independientes que si
tienes una matriz que tiene dos pilas
exactamente iguales entonces su
determinante es cero
entonces si ves dos filas o incluso
pueden ser varias filas que sean iguales
entonces ya sabes que el determinante de
esa matriz es cero y bueno aquí no lo
estoy enseñando pero también si tienes
cierto conjunto de filas las cuales son
linealmente dependientes entre ellas
entonces también el determinante de la
matriz va a ser igual a cero pero bueno
eso no te lo estoy enseñando aquí y yo
creo que lo vamos a ver en un vídeo más
adelante